S
E
ELECTING IDIOTANNO
S ITPRDACEIC
LATIS TAISN IDLEGRI  O IARCK
KATT VEU UNFIODANGINWEEDHAT T
IHADAR
BUTHAT T OOURIECRNRKHE ARIIBHI
ALDANECES D,ALIS CTEURLY
SA
AR.TICONEDAGANOO IWHL HES
ATCKBADIGOAFONBAE M
SORTAESG  RURNVNCERRNRMN Y,NCNA2
ESENMEEDOFESME
INR UBEMEDE,TIOMVE NT T A L C
BR, HE LE REYOLPR AON, ETHUN I
L WAN WS,
NS
ININA L SAAREED E AROAD , IN>>N
R OERDIRIDEINPOD CT
T
HANODETH AALME
RSST W ASO
S BUFAOFGRACN GOINTSSINTHCROM
USD LOF,S ULITLE
INTI NGOAL C
INT DUITIR CEETEVEELVE A
THNIEY BEDETNO, TH.LO
USTE GIAT TH C
LT SPALTO V
AT N
, ISN. W WHENERSZATEORANREGHLETA
UR D
RISRI?E TI
S LE H
S AGOMPWH
ISPO SIDNSST SE R TO OUS HOD ESC
NSOR